c'est un sanctuaire de la nature une
cathédrale de verdure unique au monde où
toutes les espèces n'ont même pas encore
été découverte par l'homme bornéo en
indonésie avant un taux pouvant croire
trop fort et trop salés riante un
paradis sauvage au coeur de cette jungle
un français aurélien brûlé tout le monde
ici l'appel chagny il s'est installé à
bornéo il ya onze ans déjà mais à chaque
coup de rame
il s'émerveille encore et dans
l'ensemble ça va te retrouves touché
presque sans regarder quasiment
invisible en face à la manche
aho
elle apprécie
et pourtant la beauté de ces lieux ne
tient désormais plus qu'à un fil alors
y'a rien peu fragile toutes les phases
où comme ça ça me prendrait tous les
jours de pouvoir imaginer que ça tours
et plaça trajet ont brûlé donc il faut
tout faire pour arriver recept sauver
cette forêt quoi
sauver la forêt car depuis 20 ans le
bruit des animaux est remplacé par celui
des tronçonneuses
il ya 50 ans toute la surface de bornéo
était une immense forêt mais à coup de
bulldozer
il n'en reste aujourd'hui que 30 %
les industriels coup il brûle aussi
certains mois de l'année d'immenses
fumée aveugle toute l'île les terres
libère massivement des gaz à effet de
serre l'indonésie petite puissance
industrielle est devenu le troisième
pollueur au monde c'est la disparition
programmée d'un territoire
ce que combat chagny ce sont ces
palmiers qui remplace la forêt pour
faire de l'huile l'huile de palme que
tous les industriels s'arrache
ça avance et départ pourrait y avait des
animaux spa
c'est le nouveau visage de bornéo
le combat de chagny ce sont ces singes
victime de la déforestation des singes
méconnu avec de très longs bras qui
vivent jusqu'à 30 ans à l'état naturel
les gibbons deux fois par jour
avec son équipe il va nourrir les 300
gibbons qui l'a recueilli pas encore
mangé celui-là espèces avant je vais lui
mettre quelques bananes attendait mais
chagny a créé une association baptisée
kalaweit un programme entièrement dédiée
à la préservation du gibbons donc on
porte un masque au contact des gibbons
pour éviter que j'aime ou entrave des
maladies humaines comme l'herpès qui
pourrait tuer gibbons quatre jours du
haut de ses 29 ans le petit français a
convaincu les autorités indonésiennes de
le laisser créer cette réserve de 25
hectares la déforestation a décimé ce
primate
il n'en reste que cent mille dans toute
l'île et selon les experts si rien n'est
fait le premier grand singe à
disparaître définitivement de la planète
sera une espèce de gibbons jumeaux sont
extrêmement menacée à l'heure actuelle
six sont spécialisées à la cime des
arbres à la canopée et à l'heure
actuelle avec la déforestation leur
habitat est détruit et ils ne peuvent
pas s'adapter à un environnement où il
aurait à descendre au sol ce que leur
système immunitaire est pas prêt à être
en contact avec des bactéries et
parasites présente au sol cette réserve
n'est pas un zoo mais un lieu de
sauvegarde dans ces immenses volière
chagny constituent des couples de
gibbons son but
les réhabituer à vivre en forêt pour un
jour les relâcher mais le singe est très
fragile très sensibles au stress et aux
maladies
chagny doit tester chaque animal qui
arrive à l'association il n'est pas
vétérinaires avec les gibbons c'est un
autodidacte
donc là on fait une prise de sang du gie
bon pour s'assurer qu'il n'a pas été
affectés par des maladies humaines
vous riez loup mais avant de nous
arriver la plupart du temps ils ont
passé quelques semaines ou mois chez des
gens et au contact des populations et
qu'on peut contracter des maladies
humaines
c'est le cas ils pourront
malheureusement jamais repartir dans la
nature la passion de chagny pour les
gibbons a commencé dans le var dans le
sud est de la france
c'était il ya vingt ans à son
adolescence au zoo de fréjus ont fois
par semaine toute la journée de mercredi
j'allais voir les gibbons je m'asseye
dans laquelle devant la cage pendant
plusieurs heures pour essayer de les
comprendre les observer pourrait céder
c'est ce qui se passait dans leur petite
tête et pour pouvoir ensuite mieux les
aider donc pendant cinq ans en fait une
fois par semaine à tu passais tout mon
temps libre dans les eaux assez en phase
2 pour essayer les comprendre il est bon
le gâteau cadeau de ma mort 1 ouais
c'est bon alors tout naturellement à sa
majorité
shania quitté la france pour venir
s'installer là où les gibbons vivent à
l'état naturel dans le sud est de l'asie
de manger comme un singe dimanche comme
un petit gibbon non je veux pas manger
ça mais plutôt ça il a épousé une
indonésienne et a désormais un fils de 5
ans c'est vrai que c'est très loin de
mon passé de varois
français mais
maintenant c'est une partie de moi ma
vie elle est ici et je réalise même plus
la différence ou là le changement qui a
mieux dans ma vie il nous faut sont
aussi autant indonésienne français à
l'heure actuelle du ma petite famille
avec moi mais maintenant ici donc la
maison c'est ici voilà ça s'est mis tout
le petit yannick alouettes
il a quatre mois mythos est né en
captivité dans la réserve de cacahuètes
comme tant d'autres ses parents ont été
victimes de la déforestation
c'est vraiment une petite peluche 1
tellement attendrissant
avec la forêt qui disparaît les gibbons
se retrouve au sol à la merci des
braconniers ce sont les petits qui sont
les plus recherchées on les vend sur les
marchés locaux comme animaux de
compagnie
alors inlassablement chagny parcourt la
région à la recherche de ces gibbons en
captivité il y en aurait 6000 à bornéo
qu'est ce qu'il a mangé bien gibbons
dans la cage abat sur le bateau j'ai
demandé à la dame
parmi ces morts excusez moi madame
bonjour
allan von al haq avait un tout petit
zizou
bonjour excusez moi de vous déranger je
suis chagny de l'association kalaweit
j'ai une question à vous poser en
passant j'ai vu que vous aviez un
gibbons à l'arrière de votre bateau moi
je demande aux gens s'ils veulent bien
nous rendre leur gibbons pas obligé mais
est ce que vous voudrez me le donner
pour qu'on leur mette dans la forêt non
je veux garder encore un peu grâce à
pato kaka mais vous savez si vous le
gardez dans la cage
il veut finir par mourir et qu'il n'a
pas d'eau dans la cage de 6,6 combien
lui enlever à vous venez de lui enlever
pourquoi les gens ont des gibbons comme
ça en fait c'est quelque chose d'assez
courant à bornéo en fait leymergie bons
sont tués pour la capture des jeunes qui
sont blotties sur le ventre de la maman
donc à une famille entière qui est
décimée pour être vendue comme ça lâche
0 ils sont lui s'en servent comme
animaux de compagnie comme jouets
vivants puis finissent par mourir on
voit ce petit gibbon il ya des gros yeux
et souffrent de malnutrition
je donne pas de moi
avant de mourir chagny n'a pas de
pouvoir de police et ne peut obliger les
habitants à lui cédé l'animal ces
recherches vont donc se poursuivre
ailleurs
direction le sud de l'île à une heure
d'avion delà des animaux étaient aperçus
en captivité près du lac de sel bulut au
coeur des plantations d'huile de palme
mais très vite vu du ciel bord des eaux
n'est plus qu'une succession de
cicatrices une terre tailladé déforester
[Musique]
les plantations
omettre les km2
certes avant cette étape
maintenant voilà y'a plus rien
écoeurant pas fait mal au coeur
à perte de vue sur des milliers
d'hectares
cette monoculture le palmier à huile un
arbre importés d'afrique par la main de
l'homme ici les plantations débuté il ya
quinze ans et le principe est toujours
le même
le gouvernement indonésien c'est de la
terre à des compagnies privées pour
planter exploiter les palmiers et orbi
pour la forêt où les animaux ici aucun
gibbons ne vivra plus jamais et s'il n'y
a plus d'espoir un nul n'y aura plus
jamais de forêt ici parce que le sol est
aussi pauvre que c'est fini tout est
définitif
c'est définitif n'y aura malheureusement
plus de forêt ici vous voyez c'est ça
les noix de palme et c'est avec ces lois
qu'on fait justement de l'huile et
l'huile qu'on retrouve dans les cuisines
et salles de bain occidental sous forme
de produits dans les savons les
cosmétiques l'alimentaire dans les chips
les gâteaux les pattes est vraiment nuls
qui effet répandu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de produits notre enquête va se
poursuivre sans chagny qui repart à la
recherche des gibbons
si on prouve cette huile de palme par
tous c'est que cette culture est très
rentable
l'indonésie et la malaisie sont les deux
premiers producteurs au monde de cette
huile végétale combien vous gagnez la
n10 50 par jour
une main d'oeuvre très bon marché pour
un travail physique
si je repars jouer c'est lourd c'est
lourd
combien de kilos ça fait 60 kg environ
les palmiers ne demande pas de sol très
fertile il peut vivre jusqu'à 25 ans et
tous les dix jours
pendant toute l'année on peut récolter
les noix de palme revient vous pouvez en
mettre dans un camion comme ça saigne
adam 9 tonnes
sur les routes de la région c'est un
ballet incessant de camions des
véhicules gavé de noix de palme qui
seront transformés en huile
la production a lieu dans de grandes
usines comme celle ci mais pas facile
d'y pénétrer sur les sites de production
on n'aime pas beaucoup la publicité
encore moins les journalistes dans le
village de samm boulou un homme nous a
donné rendez vous il a choisi le moment
de la prière pour être à l'abri des
regards
nous nous y rendons avec une caméra
discrète
l'homme prétend pouvoir nous aider à
entrer dans une de ses usines
mais pour établir le contact cet
intermédiaire nous réclame un bakchich
de 70 euros pour ouvrir les portes
il faut donc monnayer notre entrée
visiblement nos billets facilite les
choses
le lendemain matin le directeur d'une de
ses usines accepte de nous faire visiter
ses installations
l'homme nous fait passer les barrages et
nous laisse filmer les usines à la
condition qu'on ne puisse l'identifier
quatre cent mille tonnes de noix de
palme arrive dans cette seule unité de
production chaque année un business
juteux
car seulement vingt personnes sont
nécessaires pour faire tourner cette
affaire très rentable
et dans le secret de son bureau le
directeur reconnaît même que l'huile de
palme c'est un peu la poule aux oeufs
d'or
à votre avis combien de temps ça peut
durer ce business de l'ange de palmiste
je pense que ça peut durer toujours
athée et voici le produit fini l'huile
de palme la couleur de l'or mais surtout
celle de l'argent donc assez mboul où on
en vendant toutes les échoppes
le village est cernée par 5 plantations
dix mille personnes habitent ici ce sont
des dayak la déforestation et l'arrivée
de l'huile de palme ont bouleversé toute
l'économie locale autour du lac de
symboles ou les dayaks vivent
principalement de la culture sur brûlis
ils brûlent les végétaux pour enrichir
les sols et obtenir de meilleures
cultures
le bois est un pilier de leur tradition
et la forêt une source importante de
leurs revenus
l'ancien chef du village c'est package'
depuis les années il a vu toute sa
région changer avant ici c'était de la
forêt et c'est là que nous les
villageois nous cultivions mais
maintenant les palmiers arrive jusqu'ici
la palmeraie s'approche de plus en plus
près du village
le combat de la forêt donc déjà perdu
désormais c'est pour leurs terres que
les habitants se battent
vous savez je suis vraiment inquiet je
cultive ce champ depuis quelques années
et il est prévu que la plantation
viennent bientôt absorber cette parcelle
j'ai vraiment peur de perdre la terre
les hévéas que pas hadji a planté pour
produire du caoutchouc n'ont pas encore
été remplacées par des palmiers mais
d'autres villageois eux ont eu moins de
chance car les plantations d'huile de
palme continue de grignoter la terre
avalant au passage les propriétés des
habitants de l'autre côté de cette route
à quelques mètres des palmiers seulement
il y a une maison la maison de madame
samour gabonais madame sammour à 73 ans
et cultive son petit jardin pour
survivre vous avez peur de quitter votre
maison
je suis obligée de rester nuit et jour
pour garder cette terre parce que sinon
les compagnies d'huile de palme vont me
la prendre mon absence savez bien ils
vont reprendre le terrain et il ne me
donneront rien en échange
mme adams amour est une irréductible
mais il ne fait pas toujours bon se
poser aux combats ni d'huile de palme
à deux heures de bateau de ses boules ou
un autre village times zhang hao
là encore la forêt a été dévasté là
encore les terres ont été confisquées
pour planter des palmiers
mais ici les habitants ont résisté à
notre arrivée tout se rassemblent tous
sauf si personnes qui manquent à l'appel
une caméra des étrangers une chance pour
enfin confier leur colère c'est la photo
de mon fils il a été arrêté parce qu'il
a arraché les palmiers pour défendre le
villageois mon mari aussi a été arrêté
les compagnies l'huile de palme avait
pris terrain de mon père c est dire qu
on va l'appeler que son mari c'est mon
frère
j'étais là aussi dans ce terrain et moi
aussi j'ai arraché les petits pas lui
nuire
il ya quelques mois nous avons envoyé
des lettres à tous les nanas à la police
au chef du district et même à
l'entreprise d'huile de palme on leur a
dit de ne pas planter sur nos terres
personne ne nous a jamais répondu elles
et ils ont commencé à planter quand même
alors un jour on a arraché leurs
palmiers du terrain si la police est
venue ils ont arrêté six villageois et
les ont jetés en prison
et comment vous ressentez tout ça alors
il ya même c'est difficile
la pâte
ce serait bien sûr que c'est difficile
je croyais que l'indonésie c'était un
pays avec des lois mais nous ne sommes
que des petites gens personne ne nous
aide
alors que la grosse entreprise qui
plante n'est pas lié n'a pas été
sanctionné pour nous avoir volé nos
terrains vous savez on n'a pas de titre
de propriété pour trouver quelle cécité
à nous appartient balle ovale depuis nos
ancêtres on hérite de ses terres de
génération en génération
et puis tout d'un coup la une entreprise
arrive qu'elle prend nos terrains tous
les habitants de thann zhang hao se
mobilisent donc pour demander le retour
des leurs et que les terres leur soit
rendue au coeur de la plantation
aurélien brûlé le français qu'on appelle
chagny continue lui sa mission
il veut retrouver les gibbons captivité
qu'il pourrait sauver bonjour madame je
suis chagny de l'association kalaweit je
viens voir si vous avez des animaux
sauvages en captivité chez vous pour me
les confier des gibbons des orangs
outans on n est pas obligé hausse à
seulement si vous le voulez non non on
n'en a pas cadalen bon je vais quand
même faire le tour et c'est là on est
dans un camp d'ouvriers qui travaillent
dans les plantations à la plupart de ces
personnes sont des javanais et ils sont
là maximum depuis trois ans pour
travailler dans la plantation
donc ce ne sont pas des personnes
originaires de boire nous vient d'une
autre ils sont la plupart des deux temps
des gens très très pauvres qui est dans
les bidonvilles à java donc là parlent
un peu aux gens pour essayer de savoir
si à des jumeaux en captivité ils sont
près de 200 à s'entasser dans ses
baraquements les compagnies huile de
palme développe des écoles de petits
centres de soins pour leurs ouvriers
pas vraiment des programmes sociaux mais
un bon moyen de garder ses petites mains
au plus près des palmiers bien matin à
doha au gabon ça vous plaît journée
aurait ouais pas mal pharma sas moi ça
fait onze ans que je viens la capitale
pallanca rai1 assigne à 36 et je suis
française je me suis marié avec une
dayak ça fait onze ans que je suis là
alain delaunay là je faisais un tour
pour demander il n'y a pas de gibbons
ici donc m
avant il y en avait un de l'ohada et
maintenant il est où on l'a tué on
allait pourquoi on t'aura palais ou non
parce qu'il a mordu les gens à ramasser
ring et gras il était agressif 1 il y
avait donc bien sage ici mais ce jour là
shani est arrivé trop tard et les
gibbons ne sont pas les seules victimes
de la déforestation
à l'autre bout du lac de sam hulu prend
donc damart un petit village de pêcheurs
à en croire les habitants depuis
quelques mois il n'y a plus de poissons
dans le lac pacte war est l'un de ces
pêcheurs il habite ici depuis 15 ans et
auparavant il n'avait jamais eu de
problèmes avec l'eau du lac
il ya une image me baigner n'importe où
dans le lac et un jour je suis allée
près de l'usiné fabrique l'huile et au
sailhenc descendant sayah gala icahn
yali d'arrêt dû me mettre dans l'eau
pour débloquer mon fils et quand je suis
revenu sans gratter j'avais des plaques
rouges par total anaya et il ya des
tests qui ont été faits sur l'eau qu'on
en parlait il ya eu des tests à ces
liens mais les résultats on les a jamais
eu
on a envoyé les prélèvements quelque
part et si on nous avait donné je me
souviendrai tous les deux jours un
étrange camions sillonnent le village
partout au bord de la route des tonneaux
l'attendent
c'est un camion citerne de la compagnie
d'huile de palme voisine le lac a beau
être à quelques mètres de là ces deux
lots que le camion à porte et très vite
les employés se laisse aller à quelques
confidences
c'est quoi cette eau là ça c'est de
l'eau potable et pourquoi vous livrer de
l'eau potable ici c'est ce que l'eau du
lac est pollué ne dis pas ça toi
pour les déchets toxiques de la
plantation
une autre entreprise a fait des bassins
de décantation et on ne jette donc pas
les déchets dans la rivière et dans le
lac
bon il faut que je vous dise il n'y a
pas de problème de déchets chez nous
mais quand il pleut les bassins de
décantation avec tous les déchets
débordent dans la rivière le lac serait
donc bien pollué et dans le village en
fête
une dizaine d'habitants aurait été
affecté par cette eau souillée
qui prouve la chenille
on va dans une maison au milieu des
plantations j'en suis une info comme
quoi en fait ils ont attrapé un python
donc j'ai pas trop la situation là bas
on
on va récupérer les bidons
c'est pas un gibbons mais si on a
l'opportunité d'aider un animal sauvage
qu'on fait quand même pas si on peut le
le relâcher dans la nature dans une zone
de protéger passera bien
[Musique]
bonjour je suis chagny de l'association
kalaweit on m'a dit que vous aviez un
python il est oui il est là
vous avez trouvé ou dans la rivière ça
fait longtemps n'ont pas longtemps
oh ça c'est un gros piton ça va pas être
simple de l'attraper là je vais avoir
besoin des dégâts ok toi tu tiens la
cage et gagne en ligne tient la cage
tu va le tenir aussi gentil que par le
passé et cognac et qu'elle voit une fois
que le corps et sens tu le tiens par là
que c'est bien compris un par la queue
[Musique]
elle m'a pas dire qu'un parent
détends-toi détends-toi picot à rouleaux
déroule de tout son long
ne le laisse pas bougé chagny le sait
bien
le python est un terrible prédateur en
quelques secondes
l'animal peut tuer un homme une mort ils
entourent sa proie qui l'écrasent et
peut avaler des animaux de la taille
d'un sanglier
yannick l'espace enroulée elle tient le
bien fort
aucune chance approche le 5
vraiment
hier matin il rentre ses beaux yeux
bleus ne lâchent pas ça que des
passerelles rignac cagnotte
allez il faut faire un noeud ça va très
bien et physique
c'est physique parce que c'est un python
de quatre mètres quand même mon il va
passer quelques heures en sac
c'est pas très sympa pour lui après mais
dans quelques heures demain il sera
libre de nouveau face à une forêt
protégée
un python de récupérer mais combien de
gibbons d'orangs outans déjà sacrifié
dans cette région en indonésie selon les
experts toutes les 15 secondes la forêt
diminue de l'équivalent d'un terrain de
football
le problème est loin d'être terminée un
brillant le voile avec les petits petits
palmistes viennent juste d'être planté
l'huile de palme a vraiment un très très
bon avenir d'intérêt que les
biocarburants
ces biocarburants qui n'ont rien de bio
donc on va encore avoir ces zones
dévastées ces gens expulsés ces animaux
qui vont mourir pour cette demande
mondiale de l'huile de palme qui va en
grandissant tous les jours donc voilà le
combat est vraiment très loin d'être
terminée les biocarburants c'est un
nouveau débouché encore plus juteux pour
les compagnies dans les pépinières les
jeunes pousses attendent déjà pour être
plantés
car la production d'huile de palme
pourrait encore doubler d'ici dix ans
l'union européenne s'est fixé pour
objectif d'imposer 10% de biocarburants
dans les transports d'ici 2020
alors peut-être dans quelques années le
village de symboles ou et toutes les
autres communes autour du lac auront été
absorbée par les plantations
[Musique]
retour à pas lents de karaj à la
capitale de la province de bornéo nights
bord sam à chagny à niakara le combat de
chagny se poursuit sur radio callaway
qu'il a créé ce soir là c'est la libre
antenne
et on ne parle pas que des gibbons elle
n'y a pas de tabou ici on peut parler de
tout personne ne va te juger on est là
pour t'aider
en fait je suis avec cet homme depuis
dix mois même si je désire d'autres
hommes je sais que je laime à la
commission ne l'aiment pas car si tu les
mets tu n'aurais pas envie d'autres mecs
17 problème du volet donne aux éditeurs
ce qu'il veut à l'écouté
britney spears et toutes les
les chansons à la mode qui veut
l'écouter mais entre ses chansons entre
ces programmes de divertissement on va
avoir des messages très ciblée sur la
protection de l'environnement
voilà maintenant ça c'est un
message sur les gibbons pour pousser les
gens à nous donner leur jeu
[Musique]
smaïn wawa un matin et le bouche à
oreille fonctionne
l'ia est arrivé dans la réserve de
chagny il ya quinze jours seulement
c'est un auditeur de radio qu'à la wet
qui avait appelé pour signaler le petit
gibbon en captivité dans une famille
elle est dans quel état là cette petite
femme est sûre porte bien on reçoit
souvent des girondins plus mauvaises
conditions malheureusement pour la
capture de nez à sa famille plus de dix
ans que chaîne humaine donc ce combat
malgré les menaces les pressions et les
moments de découragement
malheureusement le danger de lier aux à
l'exploitation de la forêt à la
destruction de la forêt à ces grandes
plantations d'huile de palme
la problématique n'est pas seulement lié
au gibbons à se retrouvent pour d'abord
toutes les autres formes de vie dans la
forêt y compris les hommes parce que par
exemple à sumatra
il ya une épine genre imba qui sont
menacées de disparition eux aussi à
cause de la destruction de la forêt
pour ces fameuses plantation d'une panne
il y a quelques mois
chagny et est allé à la rencontre d oran
mba à sumatra sur l'île voisine de
bornéo
il nous a confié les images qu'ils
avaient tourné à l'époque la population
des horreurs imba diminue au rythme des
arbres qui tombent aujourd'hui ils ne
sont plus que 1500 est ce que redoute
chagny c'est la disparition irréversible
de ce peuple nomade de la forêt band
song est l'homme fort de ce groupe
il a 40 ans la forêt c'est bien plus que
sa maison c'est son identité plus la
forêt disparaît moins il ya de
ressources pour les rimes bas est
désormais les repas sont bien minces du
manioc et cette grenouille
nous n'avons rien à manger depuis des
semaines
nous ne pouvons plus rien donner à nos
enfants
il pleure il meurt de fans bientôt
peut-être leur forêt elle aussi sera
totalement rasé pour planter de l'huile
de palme si rentable mais cette fois ce
ne sont donc plus les gibbons qui sont
en danger de mort
mais ces hommes eux-mêmes et chagny n'a
jamais oublié l'appel au secours que lui
avait lancée bande dont mais avant son
départ
si vous ne comprenez pas nos difficultés
ça vous ne voulez pas nous aider alors
tu es nous tout ça
après sumatra et bornéo
l'huile de palme risque maintenant de
coloniser la papouasie une autre île
indonésienne un autre paradis de la vie
sauvage
[Musique]